[Music]
hello and welcome to the virtual edition
of our year-round member screening
series film independent presents and
this q a for boys state
currently currently streaming on apple
plus my name is jen wilson i'm a senior
programmer here at film independent
thank you to film independent presents
lead sponsor the hollywood forum press
association
and also thank you to our new virtual
screenings partner vision media
make sure to check out film independence
calendar to see what virtual screenings
we have coming up at film independent
dot org
and now i'm very excited to introduce
our guests for today they're
the directing and producing team behind
the multi award winning
2014 documentary the overnighters and
now the sundance and south by southwest
award winning documentary boys state
please welcome jesse moss and amanda
mcvayne
so since many of our film independent
members are aspiring
filmmakers and newer filmmakers um could
the two of you just
um sort of start about talking about
what your trajectory was and and how did
you
end up becoming documentary filmmakers
do you want to start
all the way back yeah actually um
there's a connection to this film too
which is
i think a really formative film for me
uh was
the war room which came out in 1994 i
was i didn't work in
film i was newly out of college i'm
dating myself but
i just graduated from college and i saw
that movie in in the theater
and the same year is actually hoop
dreams two incredible
um cinema verite films and both really
um inspired me and i i was sort of
suddenly recognized this form as being
incredible
and its ability to kind of look at what
was happening in the world and
tell dramatic stories with characters
who were as rich and complicated as
anything i'd seen
in fiction film and i quit my job in
politics and
moved to new york and started to work in
documentary film
and um didn't set out to make political
documentaries so it's
it's funny to come back kind of full
circle with this film and really make
i think a film that owes a lot of debt
to the war room
and i think hopefully hoop dreams too
and all modesty
yeah i mean like jesse i actually um
did not initially work in film and i
didn't go to film school but
i did in undergraduate study
anthropology
and um studio art so there was some kind
of
something happening in college but then
i worked
basically in advertising and at some
point recognized that i
there was something missing there was
storytelling missing in my life and
ended up going
quitting my job and going to intern for
a great
uh and small doc film company um
and pretty soon thereafter bought kind
of a cheap cheap cheap
mini dv camera uh recognizing that it
was
that i just needed to go make a film and
we met and and started making a film
pretty soon thereafter um
and what's so interesting about that
film this was a million years ago it's
called speedo and it's about a
demolition derby
car driver it's also vertex we filmed
over years and years but
um a lot of the people that worked on it
on that film with us
are still people we work with today and
that's kind of
we we just realized that recently when
someone was like what about speedo and i
was like oh my gosh jeff actually shot
jeff who cut this film worked on that
film
over 20 years ago so it's it's great
i mean i love the documentary is also a
kind of a small community and
um uh those friendships have really
nourished us
and you know uh they've been our
artistic collaborators
so so let's talk about
um how did you come to select this the
subject matter
for um your doc film boys state and
and why the uh because they do a boys
state in almost every state
i think i'm not sure but anyway so how
did you select the subject matter and
why in particular the texas boys state
they do a boy state and girl state
they're both programs of the american
legion in every state except hawaii
we're still not sure what what's going
on in hawaii
but um we'll forgive them um we i think
like
many americans were really wrestling
with the political division in our
country
post trump's election in 2016
and trying to understand how we'd gotten
to this place of
intractable difference and we
learned about the texas boys state
program um
in the newspaper we read about it in the
washington post
um because the boys in texas had
um voted to secede from the union in
2017
and that became news and caught our eye
and it was a discovery that this program
which we thought was like an
artifact of the 1950s was still very
much
around and not only that it created they
have
um built a space in which people with
different politics are actually getting
together young people
boys and girls and and debating and
arguing and
trying to find common ground and that's
a rare space in american life today and
we
were really interested in like what
would it be like to bring our camera
there and make a film in that space so
that was the jumping off point
um so when you're making a film like
this um
with so many kids in it is it is it hard
to identify who
who you'll end up focusing on as main
characters
um i'm do you end up interviewing a lot
of kids
for at first and then narrowing down
it's great question and i think this
project was really different than any
other project we really
embarked on because usually we do
take years and years and years to shoot
a film
and so we will take our time to discover
the people who will be
the people that we're most interested in
in uh
any story right um so for the
overnighters i mean jesse shot
over two year 18 months or something um
one week every month or 18 months
this time though we knew we had one week
to capture the film and if we didn't get
it in that week we didn't have a film
which is
crazy high risk high reward hopefully um
filmmaking and kind of exciting but also
daunting in the sense that
we knew we couldn't cast when all of it
once we got there we
just wouldn't have time to find the
right people who really
um grabbed us so we did spend three
months before
the event um traveling all around texas
interviewing many many many many people
filming many many many many people
in their homes you know we met all kind
you know
all kinds of kids and a lot of them were
really interesting and
multifaceted i think though out of the 1
100 people we could have
featured we did once we
found our three three and eventually
four main characters it was pretty
obvious
kind of almost in in instantly oh there
you are we've been waiting for you
um they're all very different
politically they all have very different
backgrounds
um but they're all they all have a
certain something i don't know if i can
be told it's not a totally rational
thing but there's certain something that
we were looking for um and they were
politically savvy enough that we knew
that they would or we hoped they would
do well
once the program got started
is there a possibility that you would
ever do a sequel to this and do a girls
state
totally absolutely i i think um
we're really interested in um
and seeing how how they build their
government
and what what what is different about it
um
we're we're looking at different
programs in different states and i don't
think we'd go back to texas
i think it'd be interesting to go
somewhere else um texas has
a lot going on it's it's a purple state
it's not red it's not blue it's a kind
of a great canvas to explore and i think
a
state other states like that so it could
be florida ohio
um pennsylvania massachusetts is not a
red state but but it's an interesting
state they have a very robust program
for girls there so
we'd love to make we don't call it a
sequel we call it a sibling
we'd love to to make that sibling
uh i read a review for this film i i
think and i'm i'm not sure
it was by manila dargus at new york
times and i'm not sure if she was
reviewing it
out of uh sundance or more recently
but she said she described this movie as
a happy pill of a movie
it which was not my impression
of the film either time i saw it i saw
it sundance and then
you know um i watched it again for this
interview
um there's something
about and i don't know if it's just me
or not but you can tell me the other
impressions that people have
have given from watching the movie
there's something about gatherings of
young men i think that now since
charlottesville
there's a feeling of uneasy uneasiness
about gathering of groups of young men
now i think
has anybody else sort of expressed that
opinion of there's an
there was an air of of menace to it
somehow at times
i think i think all takeaways are fair
because we really do offer
a lot of of um i think we saw the best
on display and we saw the worst on
display i mean we see a little bit of
everything
um and a little bit of that is the dream
and a little bit is the nightmare
um of america right so uh
i do i am not surprised that some people
listen people come to our film when they
bring their own emotion
they bring their own politics but they
also bring their own emotions about
politics
to this particular um their own teenage
experience and their own teenage
experience and all of those things
are really vivid for people and so
i'm not surprised that we sort of elicit
different emotions out of people and
also different
like levels of you know kind of extreme
reactions
um personally there were moments that i
found very terrifying
um i also though
was surprised in fact i i kind of
i knew going in that i was going to see
a certain degree of lord of the flies
kind of pandemonium kind of
uh you know maybe some toxic masculinity
a little bit of this a little bit of
that and then what i was surprised by i
think
actually once i got there is is some of
the stuff i hadn't expected which is
um the degree well like stephen's
empathic leadership
style and to the degree that that was
successful
in that space of um you know
17 year olds in that space of boys and
that space of
um you know heavily conservative and
predominantly white
majority i was actually surprised how
effective
uh how much they wanted to be um
believing in someone who with principal
principled politics i thought that was
really interesting and surprising to me
so for you know again my it's all
depends on who you are and and
also maybe how you where we are in the
news cycle too i mean this is i've never
made a
directly political film before and and
where we are
on any given week with any given thing
happening in the world really does
have a certain effect on how you watch
this film it's interesting
yeah i i think for me having watched it
again more recently
since kova 19 and the black lives matter
and you fund the police and everything
else that's been going on
um it was more emotionally charged for
me
especially you know when we get because
i got so emotionally attached
to steven um
that i just cried from the second that
he
you know didn't win all the way through
to all those kids coming up to him and
expressing their
um sentiments um
you know he's such a gifted kid uh i'm
wondering um if you know what he's doing
now and
and if he was um sort of approached by
anybody who saw this
to sort of help mentor him into a a real
political career
yeah we're very close to all of the boys
till they first they came to sundance
everyone
except robert who was at west point and
couldn't couldn't come but
they've been a really big part of our
conversation with audiences
virtually um in covet and they've
they've grown a lot they're two years
older and
it's really um um
interesting to hear them reflect on
particularly ben on reflect on his
actions and
um sort of how he's come to
recognize the toxicity that
he embodied himself and sort of to
disavow his his
negative campaigning um has been
meaningful
for us to hear um stephen they're all
very engaged politically now
um and in this moment um how could they
not be stephen is
um i think has a future in electoral
politics he's
um definitely received some offers of
support people are really
um recognizing that he is a remarkable
young man so actually we just heard
today that
julian castro is interested in meeting
with him and having a conversation
i know that the texas state legislature
represents the rio grande valley where
stephen is from has
made him an offer when he can get to
austin he's in remote schooling now at
home in houston but he's a student at ut
austin but that
legislator would like stephen to come to
work for him and so i think people
um absolutely have recognized that he is
a
um a future leader he's a leader now and
he has a powerful voice
and that we need to hear more from him
um and he remains
um an optimist you know i mean there's a
lot of negativity which amanda talked
about it and you mentioned
at boys state that energy that's
frightening and a kind of
militant masculinity but stephen
embodies something very different very
hopeful
and i think something that we can all be
inspired by and we certainly need that
now
um and renee too renee is um much more
involved in
um black lives matter and activism in
his local community even though he has
i think would have as bright a future in
electoral politics if that was the path
that he chose he's chosen
now to focus more on community activism
so it's been really interesting to see
the different paths that each of these
boys has taken now
uh so so has since the film
has come out and and ben has seen it has
he sort of
um come out and said that he
no longer feels that his tactics that he
used were fair
yeah i mean he's it that started um
really with watching the rough cut of
the film i think that he
he he's fun he's a funny funny he's
brilliant but he's also a very
funny guy and he was saying you know i
kind of expected the
when i went to watch the ref cut i
expected the
ben hit real show you know and then
seeing
you know the other side humanized which
he had
no way to see because they really the
two parties are pretty separate
really was very moving for him
and then to obviously now spend a lot of
time first at sundance with stephen and
renee
and then also in all these conversations
i think part of it is just growing up
and part of it is having the perspective
of getting to know the other side as
human beings
but the other piece of it honestly is
just he's a deep patriot
and i think he sees that the country is
two
three years further into this
very divided place and i think he
recognizes the win at all cost strategy
which to some degree boy state
kind of provokes by having this
two-party system
um uh which he won
you know he did win the election for
eddie or you know
i think he sees that you may win the
election but then what
you have a divided body politic a
wounded body politic and i think that
he real recognizes now that democracy is
in a fragile fragile place and that may
not be worth it
um so that's been really interesting to
hear him talk about
he's much more articulate than i am and
um
so i wish he were here to to tell you
because it moves me every time he talks
about it
um but they're all very close and also
he's so evenly matched and
and such renee and ben
already going back to sundance would
have these two to three hour
conversations about any given subject
and it was just
incredible i wanted to just film that
forever
because they really are so different but
but
respect each other on this level that's
pretty interesting you know
um renee's uh
arc in the movie he's certainly
um after steven the set you know not
after stephen equal to stephen an
equally inspiring character
what such a magnificently
intelligent um
high school kid at at times i couldn't
believe
you know that um your main subjects were
high school kids because i'm just like
what kids is thinking about politics at
this level
um and i think it was obvious that you
know many of the part
other participants there weren't
thinking of politics at that level
but um uh yeah renee just a really
um brilliant kid and um you know you
made this before
all the black lives matter stuff but
i've
do you feel that it's um
what renee goes through in this ended up
being
such a um
you know the fight that the
he has to fight for himself so much more
than the other candidates
and i think after all the black lives
matter stuff
uh all of that hit me so much harder
have you have you heard anybody else
say that about the film absolutely i
mean i think we
we felt it i i don't think we were
surprised
that um
he certainly wasn't surprised but uh the
racism the racism surface the way it did
and this sort of
simulation and you know um
[Music]
had this chapter to it i mean i think
that it's that's not a surprise to him i
do
you know again when we were at sundance
and he
somebody stood up in one of the um q a's
and said
you are james baldwin reincarnated
and like renee did a little dance and i
was like it was the first time that it
struck me like
there's something to him that is such an
old soul it's like he's been around the
planet a couple times
and he's just arrived in this place that
his his sort of he had a solidity to him
that was really surprising
actually all of the main characters did
maybe in a way that i just don't recall
anybody i knew
at 17 having and so if anybody could
have handled what he handled
uh at boy state it was him and i think
certainly looking
back at what's happened over the last
six months um has a prison to think
about
renee's trajectory and stevens too but
these young men who come in with
um you know their voices that have been
marginalized and they're they're in the
minority in this very conservative very
white environment and they find a way
politically to navigate that space to
build political power
to find common ground to confront some
hard realities too and i think that
narrative um which we deeply connected
with is
you know is is the story of our moment
and
that that um that that um
you know renee finding a way to to reach
across and summon
the the people in that room which he can
do because he's like an adult in a room
full of boys and you really feel that in
his speech
um but instantly challenged instantly
delegitimized you know these questions
you know playful but very serious
challenge around
um impeachment and you know that how
he had to you know he he's very
progressive and
but he knew that you know in his
negotiations with his
policy committee and the party the
nationalist party that he had to walk a
very
um narrow tightrope and which he does
um and i think that you know he rene
wrote a very powerful
op-ed for the new york times about what
that experience meant to him and how
it's actually turned him away from
electoral politics to
to activism and i think he feels like
the experiment of boys state
was acaustic in a way that um which is
you know i think um i think we all
recognize that
as the boys in that room did that he he
should be an elected representative he
can be a leader but he's chosen to lead
in a different way
um and i have no doubt that he'll bring
his political skills to bear
as he is right now in his community
um so renee says in the film
um something about he's never seen
he's never seen so many white people in
his whole life
um is this an issue with boys state do
you know that anybody has ever brought
up with the american legion the fact of
it
of their just not being gender or um
racial equality uh in the kids that are
chosen to
participate in this we brought it up
with them i mean we
talked about it with i think the
leadership staff of
texas boys state who invited us in to
make this film is
recognizes that this program has one
foot in the 1950s and one foot in the
21st century they have a lot of work to
do
um that we think should mean
integrating boys and girls together and
make people state which is what stephen
asks for
um but i and i think they're working
hard to
ensure that the program reflects texas
today not texas of yesterday
right yeah i mean there's definitely
some vestiges of it having
been a program that's been going on
forever since the 1930s
and draws more heavily
from like rural small town
you know communities and less from some
of the bigger urban centers and that's
what they're working very hard right now
to address again they have a lot of work
to do to better represent the actual
demographics of texas which then the
conversation would be very very
interesting because then you really have
a pr
you know that purple conversation um
that being said steven and renee still
again going back to the magic of what
actually happened for me is that they
still
you know they are brilliant we know that
but then they
got the they got a response that to me
was really a surprise and uh
very exciting imagine what would happen
if the demographic actually represented
texas then
then then that would be really
interesting and we might have had
stephen as a winner
um were you surprised um
when um when when steven lawson and all
those kids
started coming up to him with tears in
their eyes was that something you
expected
i'm not at all surprised that so many
people loved him
um on a level that that was that that
felt very authentic and very deep and
because truly he he has a magnetism
and a empathy like a well like a deep
kind of empathy that's that not many
people you meet have
and it's and it's almost immediate and
you feel heard and you feel
held and you feel all these things right
i am i am
still surprised at how vulnerable
you know again this maybe was a failure
of my imagination with teenage boys or
american teenage boys but i'm just not
used to seeing
teenage boys cry and so um
american teenage boys cry and so that
was really interesting to see the level
of emotion but we were
we were crying i mean everybody we were
all very upset
um but i think that i'm not surprised
that he had this incredible connection
with all these people in his little city
and then obviously the wider group
i we had such a deep emotional
experience making the film and going on
that journey with him and i think one of
the reasons the edit took such a long
time it took a year
to really find the right rhythm to the
film
and the structure but the film was to to
approximate the emotional experience
that we had was really our
our goal to try to get to that place and
um
it was so important because we we did
feel that exhilaration of his ride
you know his speech when he suddenly
kind of reveals that he's
an incredible orator um and
we were devastated when he lost i think
we wanted the hollywood ending and i
think it took us a long time to actually
reconcile with the outcome but
ultimately to see that it it's
well it's what happened it's real life
and um
as steven himself says that you know you
become strong by defying defeat i think
there's
a powerful lesson in the narrative i
think we want to kind of many of us kind
of undo
what happened in 2016 and they think the
film
doesn't sort of undo that for us um but
um steven's um
[Music]
stephen's trajectory through his life
has been one of defying defeat i mean
he's in face enormous hardship
personally as he talks about the film he
his mother was undocumented and she
worked in a gas station he's
he's struggled but he he has always been
resilient and always been hopeful and
um that's what makes him special um
so i think his his um
i love that he quotes napoleon too
um who does that so
um so you opened the film with the the
george washington quote
about um uh how political parties can be
used by
undisciplined men to subvert the power
of the people and usurp for themselves
the reigns of government
when at what point in making a film like
this
do things like that emerge is it is it
not until your editing process that you
sort of like
see the result of what you shot and and
sort of pull out
um themes like this deep in the edit
probably deeper in the edit than you
ever want to admit to i mean i really
think
um first of all there's a million
incredible statements about democracy
to choose from which you know we did a
lot of reading and
um sort of on the beginning and the end
of democracy a lot of people have a lot
of things to say about both of those
things
um so that was a really late um but
i think that the what what was important
to us
early in this film um
is to to point an arrow at the real
world
so that people do recognize going into
this simulation that there is a
resonance
um at least as we saw it um
and which i think actually is pretty
obvious when you're in the simulation
but i do
also think it's really interesting that
at the beginning at the
writing of this whole american
experiment people were already
recognizing some of the challenges of
electoral politics or um
the challenges of compromise or that you
know what makes us vulnerable
well if two parties are fighting with
each other then we're all more
vulnerable to
somebody uh some under undemocratic
somebody
so i think that's a really interesting
um thing about that quote in particular
do you have a a a a prediction for
future
boys states do you think that um
some kids might might even start going
as far in the in the next boy's state as
suggesting
that the two-party system is a complete
failure
yeah it would be really interesting it's
a great question to be asking and i
think that they've asked it in texas i
think they've experimented with that
which is good and i think they should
continue to experiment um
because it does reproduce as you see
for better and for worse well mostly for
worse but the sort of tribalism the
tribal conflict
and these boys are are shouting from the
stage about beating the other party
before they even know what their party
stands for and it's sort of like they've
taken this
sports metaphor competition kind of into
their
sense of what politics should look like
and i think it's a fair question to say
can we
create another experiment that might
lead to a healthier
outcome on the other hand you could
argue that
you know the best tool for teaching is
the current system that is for better
for worse what we live with we live with
a two-party system we have
rogue third-party candidates who
sometimes affect the outcome of an
election at the presidential level but
we're kind of stuck with the system for
now so i don't expect boys state or girl
state to kind of solve our problem of
the parties
i mean they didn't figure it out the
founding fathers didn't figure it out
they knew it was a hazard i think we
live with that hazard every day in our
lives now
um the warning that washington offered
is our
current reality um i also think what's
really interesting
about the sort of anecdotal experience
at least
that we ex we saw but then also we heard
from the leadership of yours
before it's a little bit organic and
change i mean so for instance the
legislature
in 2017 and the reason we got there they
voted
to secede from the union right that's
what that group did and then the next
year the big vote
was to pass a you know bipartisan
um universal background check bill you
know so it's sort of like
you know i think there's a little bit of
an unpredictability it's not it's sort
of like this weird like lurching and
fluxing and forward and sideways thing
that american
sort of history does in terms of
progress or regression
um or compromise or separation or you
know it's like this
weird i couldn't predict for you what
this next group would do actually is my
answer
uh so the character of robert who
um with his kind of 70s haircut and
cowboy boots reminds me of matthew
mcconaughey and daisy confused
totally was so interesting to me
um because
from the beginning of the movie he was
the person i i looked at and was like
this kid's going to annoy me so
bad um but then you know his arc is
he has that amazing interview where he's
talking about how
inspired he was by stephen so much that
he
you know might resign
running um
his character more than anyone else
speaks to
the immaturity of high school kids but
also
within that he seemed to recognize that
he
still had growing to do
do you think that um
that these kids are going to change a
lot from the time
that this is made like do you do you see
they've already changed a lot in the two
years since
you made it i mean i think robert's
capacity for growth
in that experience in that week did that
certainly surprised us we knew robert
was
complicated because he is on the surface
like this richard link later dazed and
confused character which
and any filmmaker is making a movie
about texas teenagers he
you know acknowledges they work in the
shadow of that film and
for you know and so when robert
came down the stairs in his very nice
house in austin to present himself we
both kind of swooned and and but you
know he's really smart
um robert he had paged in the u.s senate
he was
thinking about political division in
america and he talked about those
feelings with us when we were casting
and it's one of the reasons we were
drawn to him so we knew he had depth
i don't think we realize well first of
all we didn't know that he was not being
truthful about his
political views that was a confession
that
he offered that really i think shocks us
shocked us as much as it shocks the
viewer
um i think that also what we've been
told was that the program
could could be transformative for young
people that the
challenges the moral questions they
confront really does force a
transformation
a coming to know thyself and to witness
that in robert and
his respect and kind of true respect for
stephen
um for taking the high road when he took
the low road
um was something that um i mean made us
kind of fall in love with robert all
over again
um and um you know he's he's taken a
very
particular trajectory now post-voice
state he's gone to west point
um we get these photographs from him
with his buzz cut
and there's like a a giant you know
artillery
gun in the background i mean it's he's
just living a different life and that's
the life he's chosen for himself and
um and and but he's um
you know he's talked i think really
powerfully about service and what
service means to him and
um i think all of these boys as
different as they are
they remind us that um and their level
of engagement um
and and their ability to kind of change
that um
um you know that you can't stand on the
sidelines and you know whatever
way you you need to get involved in some
way you need to find a path that's true
to you and
robert's found out this is a kid who had
when we met him in his room a lego model
that was like as big as our dining room
table of
uh an afghan village with us troops
patrolling the streets i mean this was
what he was thinking about so
he's he's he's finding his way to you
know
to to who he wants to be um i mean it
was really really interesting for us to
to film because the the surface
um robert the performative robert the
guy
on stage saying one thing is so
different from what's going on
inside i think that's always kind of
exciting when you find somebody like
that
at least as a storyteller it's just it
is exciting um
and i think you know to your point about
high school
and bringing you know when you make a
high school film i think you do bring a
little bit of your high school self to
that film and so yes when he showed up i
was like
you're matt dillon you know and and then
and then you know things shift and turn
and get more complicated and dimensions
are revealed and
and he becomes you know who who he is
and all of his sort of
um contradictions and i love that so
robert
robert really is actually quite a
gentleman he really is and he is a
deep respect and affection and support
for stephen that
continues to this day they're talking
about writing um
an op-ed together which i hope they do
steven and robert because i think they
think they have something to say as
representatives of the nationalist party
at texas boys state they
they have a message for the world and we
haven't read it yet but
we're looking forward to it that would
be really interesting for those two
to unite yes i think that would be
really great
i'm looking forward to that there's a
shot
um of course the ut austin campus
was the the site of that shooting from
the tower
i think in the 60s or the 70s
i was like there's a shot with all the
kids kind of gathered
beneath it uh were you thinking about
that at all at the times that you
um shot footage of the tower i was
yeah um the the
we knew that so every year there's some
issue that kind of percolates to the top
um
at any given uh boys or girls state
and so in years past there have been
like issues like uh the big issue of
another year had been
speed limits or something really kind of
boring and
i can't thank goodness that was not our
year we knew that our year
was going to be guns because um
parkland had happened only a couple
months
before that and then actually two weeks
before
um the 2018 texas texas boys state got
started
there was another um school shooting at
a high school
just north of houston so um
this was on everybody's minds these are
high school students um
you know this was even before we knew
that stephen was so involved with march
for our lives so we knew this was going
to be a debate plus it's texas right so
there's a lot of passion around guns and
gun ownership and
um i i think
that for that conversation to be
happening on
ut campus was not lost on me and um but
i'm not sure that
the students the boys at boys state i
don't think they
oh they did i've i heard many of them
actually
yeah yeah it's uh it's especially with
that tower
um uh but i think it was more
you know these are young people who
that's like there were actually
two survivors of the santa fe high
school shooting at boys state there's a
scene in the film where stephen is
talking to a young man at the
in the dining hall it's a section of the
film where he's talking about compromise
and that
boy was there for that shooting and and
stephen
sought him out and they had a
conversation they actually have very
significant political differences when
it comes to gun
uh regulation um but i think stephen
came away
i think with a deeper understanding of
that boy's position
um and so there were i mean that was
powerfully felt in every way
uh for sure that issue at boys state
uh okay we'll take some audience
questions the first one is
uh rene otero steven garza 2040.
um the next question is how do you think
the film can be used as an educational
tool to teach children about the
political process
great well on our website boyce state
dot move
we have a a curriculum that we worked on
with a24 and apple
for educators high school teachers um
and
it's i think it's great it's a great
starting point for a conversation and we
love that this film can be
shared with students and also watched by
parents and their kids and we've never
made like a family-friendly movie before
the overnighters are
a little bit intense for at least for
our kids and um
but this movie sparks i think great
conversation um both for teenagers and
even kids we're actually doing a very
robust college tour virtually too and um
we we just um we did a class um
jillapura's class on democracy at
harvard we talked about the film so
it's a wonderful to feel like this movie
can provoke debate and conversation and
i think it's really um
you know we love that it was playful to
make playful to
to present as a film and i think it you
know a film that makes us laugh and cry
and
think about some of these deeper
questions around our democracy and
electoral politics um
if i can find its way into the classroom
i think that's great
uh next one can you talk about your
cinematic approach
the film looks great what influenced the
cameras and lens choices for the film do
you have an artist or piece of art in
mind before shooting
ah that is a good question and um
again because this was going to be this
intense week
and all 1100 of the people featured in
it
we're going to be wearing white similar
white shirts and we're going to be
shooting in
like institutional you know ut campus
um classrooms and you know we were kind
of afraid of the
the way that this film might um
might look because we knew that there
would be many meetings and there was it
could be very talky movie
and so once uh jessie
um got torsen tilo who's the who's our
main
main dp uh on board who's incredible
um he brought with him a bunch of folks
from
uh new york who have they have what's
called a camera collective
um and they're all very experienced uh
cinema verite shooters
um and very skilled technically but also
poets and we knew that they'd be able to
um really get in there and make
something beautiful but in order to
organize
all these six cameras that we had out in
the field
um visually we needed to have a kind of
road map and set
uh the look for the film and so so that
was very intentional we shot
on the film on a 35 millimeter prime
lens and actually
the whole movie was shot at a consistent
f-stop f2
same lens same camera for all the
shooters and that's a very shallow depth
of field and to the question
one movie that we were inspired by
torsten and i talked about
um is a scripted narrative film called
son of saul um which is very intense
um handheld movie but with a very
shallow depth of field a very kind of
subjective
point of view you're often right behind
the subject who's kind of moving quickly
through this crowded and very chaotic
and confusing environment which
in that film happens to be a death camp
it's about the holocaust
and a very powerful emotional film and
the way in which this
the story and the visual style kind of
converge was just
instructive to us and so we um we knew
we were going to really
be hand held we were going to be
shooting close which was what the access
allowed us to do and
shooting on that shallow f-stop i mean
this close which is
uh martina radwan claudia rashke
wolfgang hell daniel carter
patrick bresnan just an amazing a team
of
cinematographers
we also chose to film widescreen um
white screens yeah uh you know so
there's
spielberg use this in in filming lincoln
right so
which is also political so you really
get this
great landscape look with the whole you
know the whole of congress
listening to lincoln right you can have
that real single
person talking to a group um in this
kind of
you know vast wide sort of is really
exciting by sort of
cutting the head room and pushing the
frame wider you you sort of
compress your so there's two people
talking and the reactions yeah
that's kind of great yeah you you can
get like right speaker and reaction
without panning or cutting and that was
something we also
we never shot a movie in widescreen and
a widescreen handheld
is a little bit of a risk um and we had
to persuade
concordia studio our partner um to take
that risk with us which fortunately they
did
thank you for talking about about that
also specifically it's a
um i know our filmmaker members
appreciate um getting
hands-on information about filmmaking
and but also it's really interesting for
me to hear because
um you know i'm also a big fan of son of
saul
spectacular and uh it's it's always
interesting to hear
you know what uh physically boots on the
ground has to be done to create a look
that you
enjoy so much
so last question um
you worked on a netflix series called
the family
about a covert religious organization
trying to control washington
i'm curious when you think about um
this film in comparison to that series
um and compare and contrast
do you how how do you think how do you
feel like that fits together as a whole
with your
career um yeah well we talk about that
too in relation
to the overnighters um but i think i
think that what
what unites them is a desire for us to
um to go to a place that we
or a community that we is very different
from our own um
to have a conversation in person and
through the camera
with people who um whether they're you
know
in the case of the family they're um
devout christian
and very conservative which neither of
which we are
um i think the idea of going to texas to
a
program that was predominantly
conservative and to see how
some young people who were not um as
conservative navigated that space
i think um to have to have a
conversation sort of across the divide
that
you know we're talking about in america
that cultural and political
social divide that we all feel and we
know kind of jeopardizes this
american experiment is the work that
we've tried to do and we've tried to
respect
and honor the complexity of that space
and those conversations
to not reduce our world and those people
to
binary black and white good and bad
people and i think we've talked about
robert and ben
and you know some of these young men in
this film who make bad
sometimes scary decisions they're still
you know people we respect and we like
and are friends with and
i think that's ultimately what we have
tried to do with boys state is to sort
of honor the complexity of the spaces we
found it and the complexity and humanity
of the people we met
um and that that means that there's a
complicated take away
um that sometimes makes you know makes
it hard for people to parse but i think
that's also what
makes the work valuable for us
well thank you so much to the two of you
for uh
all your thought your incredibly
thoughtful responses to my questions
i feel like i could talk to you for
several more hours
uh you're both incredibly uh amazing
filmmakers
and and really interesting to talk to so
thank you so much for this film
and um yes
uh good luck during award season which
is coming up
um yeah thanks jenna watching the film
twice
yeah really appreciate it it's great to
have a conversation with you about it
and thank you everybody for watching the
film and and if you have
um new questions reach out to us or
people want to put it on the curriculum
let us know we'll help out so thank you
guys all right
thank you everyone next time
you